all right we're back with Justin Kahn
CEO and co-founder of atrium go check
out atrium Co they provide legal
services to everybody it's aimed at
we'll talk about journaling in a second
but let's talk about atrium you like me
have caught in those legal bills
it's like PDF yeah when you open that
you open the PDF and you know what's
gonna happen it could be dangerous
sometimes you see this like 12 heard
your box you're like yeah like you want
the slot yeah it's like you've won the
lottery 100 and then other times you
open it and it's like 20,000 and you're
like what just happened to me it's like
when you're at the club yeah oh yeah
they bring the thing they bring the
thing and you're like who ordered yeah
there's the two bottles of Cristal on my
bill and it's $8,000 and then there's
like 20% gratuity auto included and you
won fifteen hundred additional gratuity
you know you've there's a line there you
know feels bad right and you're in the
club at 4:00 in the morning and you're
like I have to pay now I have to pay
eight and I just want to go home that's
exactly like opening your legal bills
that's so and there that's how atrium
came about popping bottles at the club
and then not be open my legal bill Oh at
1 Oak and then boom boom it was like no
I need to I've been here for three hours
I can't do it cost me $3,000 an hour to
be here $50 per minute price of being in
this club was it worth $50 per minute
yes no no it wasn't that's exactly right
and so my experience with legal was that
it was always random like playing you
know when I open legal bills I didn't
understand it people would his
experienced entrepreneurs were like no
you should just cross off 20% of the
things and send it back and I was like
that's a way you're supposed to buy
things and yeah and then I always felt
the service was really excellent
sometimes like there were moments at
justin.tv where we had such excellent
lawyers who helped us through these very
trying moments and we were like I really
respect this person's expert advice and
then there were other times when we
would email and that get no response and
so I always wonder why is there is such
an inconsistent delivery services and
why isn't this entire why do these law
firms that sort of the biggest
technology companies of world they don't
use any technology in themselves like we
had just so
right before it started hm I incubated
this company called all Alto which is a
vertical eyes pharmacy for four it's
like a star easy and I took a look at
the how's that doing there
we're doing doing good yeah good yeah
expanded to across Southern California
as well it's going pretty well fertility
is a big market for the pharmacy you
were right there again with that one
because now you look there's all these
like direct-to-consumer right get your
propecia get your viagra they want a
sponsor one of these one that's the
sponsor the podcast are like Roman their
lows and because every time we take a
sponsor I have to you have to be like I
use I have to believe I use Roman every
day and let me tell you let me tell you
right now I can't stand up if I know
it's literally like they're like would
you talk about chewable viagra and I'm
like there's two above viagra yeah hmm
how much do I get is part of the
sponsorship endorsement yeah and that
way you're paying in kind or you can hi
I'm Jason Calacanis for chewable viagra
it's amazing
publicist so yeah pharmacy is blown up
yeah but anyways we have AK th incubated
this company they were just raised
seventeen million dollar series B but
the problem was it took forever and the
company was like threading the needle on
cash and so I had the whole time I was
texting the CEO I'm like what's going on
and he was like I don't know it's with
this lawyer or this lawyer you know
somewhere in the process and then I sat
down with his lawyer randomly who's a
partner at Wilson's encinia and I asked
her this was she was a friend of a
friend we just ran him they happened to
meet up and I was asking her why don't
you guys use asana or Trello or some
sort of project management so yeah
people can see what's going on and she
was like well it's hard to get people to
adopt it internally and we don't want to
pay for it like you build a thousand
dollars an hour how okay yeah well it
would've sold forty dollars even more I
was an investment trouble it's nothing
and we use the sauna now and it's
nothing right in fact a sauna is so free
that there was no reason for us to pay
for it and they came in thing free it's
it's too free and there I was like what
is the paid version get you know like oh
maybe private but I'm like why would we
have a private board like inside a
15-person company and I'll say what is
it course is like $1500 for the year I
say pay them yes I want to pay them
because I want the service to continue
yeah let's get the pro count
if we don't need I did the same thing
with grammerly yeah I was like let's pay
for grammarly even if we don't need to
like yeah the premium version doesn't
have an executor it's like a chair it's
like when you you know you're tipping
like on what saying like earn calm or
whatever that whatever that want that
the short-term loan thing is where you
just it's you guys entirely on tips
right it's just like they used to call
it there was a category of software
shareware their way care whether this
was like the egalitarian like hey what
you think yeah it's like those albums
that you can download you pay whatever
it's like yeah a dollar or twenty bucks
or what hey but you can it's like yoga
class like pay which you that's how yoga
started in America you know that was the
business model was they would just put a
bowl in the front and say pay what you
can was the honor system that makes I
mean I think that more stuff should
operate like that I tried it at Equinox
they were like no we have to sign a
three-year contract for a hundred
seventy a month yeah so anyway you get a
legal bill so I so I mean no I was
talking all or and project me I was like
why don't you you know opted to build
something that opted don't you improve
your services over time while you spend
time operationalizing them building
software etc and their law firms are
just it turns out they're not set up in
America to do that yeah there's some of
the oldest institutions in America you
know some of the oldest companies in San
Francisco are law firms and so they're
just not set up there you know to
actually improve over time and we felt
like by building a technology company
and we could build something that was
because substantially different and so
that was the idea behind atrium started
about 18 months ago with as a
partnership between a law firm run by my
legal co-founders Augie break oh and
then we partnered with a technology
company that we all started and raised a
bunch of money into ah that's an
interesting way to start it so you found
a boutique law firm that had how many
attorneys well so Augie basically left
and started a boutique law firm God he
was a partner at auric and then we
partner together with this like
technology company that kind of runs all
of the tech and bunch of there and so if
somebody uses it is it cheaper better
faster what's the value proposition of
nature absolutely so everything is like
quote upfront pricing so that you always
like rain pay it's a flat rate for the
kind of basic services such as corporate
transactional services so I'll like
thing
like issuing equity doing your employees
you know board meetings like doing any
sort of like normal day-to-day corporate
transactional work and then if you and
is that the same cost as if you used
Wilson or Fenwick or the idea is to
model of the same cost but to do it in a
like a fixed pricing subscription way ha
and then afterwards if you have like
projects so your series a financing so
you be financing you're selling your
company whatever it is I will do quote
upfront pricing for those projects yeah
we basically hired a bunch of attorneys
from all these law firms that you know
that you would normally use in Silicon
Valley like Wilson or cool et cetera and
so the idea is there's there's kind of
that component we're building technology
to streamline delivery services it's
everything from you know workflow
software project management software
honestly it's not rocket science and
stuff that you think should exist
already yeah and I mean they use
document management know where they can
pop up a form and Duke was actually my
first job when I was in New York was
installing PC docks and soft solutions
which were like layers on top of
Microsoft Word or WordPerfect you know
she just do versioning cuz versioning
wasn't built into those things every
time in the 90s yeah it's crazy when you
think about it and so and then we you
know we've started build a bunch of ml
software to understand documents and
then turn them into structured data so
basically we want to understand the
world of first startup documents
eventually the rest of kind of the
universe of documents turn them into
structured data and understand exactly
like basically all the documents that
exist for our clients we want to be able
to turn them into like data a data layer
and then on top of that build workflow
apps that enable you to do legal work
much more quickly well if you think
about it like a video game yeah and like
what Sam's doing with open AI you know
beating
what is it dota the game they play yeah
DOTA DOTA like they beat dota players
right or whatever they beat Starcraft
players and then deepmind at Google beat
go and you know they've obviously deep
blue beat chats a long time ago if you
just look at legal services corporate
legal services if you had the corpus of
all the data yeah and you put a bunch of
AI machine learning people on it you
could solve the game
of legal is that what you're doing
you're solving the game of legal I think
yeah there's always gonna be a lot of
people come in and say are you replacing
attorneys and that's not the goal the
goal has always been let's get the best
attorneys and enable them to do the
things that they love to do which is
advising clients that's something that I
got the most value of as a court all
this stuff behind the scenes like
drafting the first version of documents
or you know like recalling data and
accessing data that stuff can be done in
a substantially faster way and that's
what we're trying to do so really put
the attorney front and center and enable
them to be more efficient and advise
better
is there an arbitrage going on by
geography as well I mean as you and I
both know this town has just gone
bonkers in terms of real estate and cost
there may be an anti arbitrage for us
because we are both based in San
Francisco I know that's bonkers I heard
you have over a hundred people in San
Francisco that's right why not open an
office in like an O state tax
Austin or Seattle Nevada where attorneys
can live for one-third the price I think
eventually that might be something we do
I really think it's important right now
our customers are the clients are in San
Francisco and also you know it's it's
kind of in those early days you're still
building culture it's really important I
think to have people in the same place
mm-hm but eventually they'll be that
that would be goal that is interesting
have you ever run a remote company have
or do you not believe in that no I
believe in it my problem actually with
remote is that more myself I think I
don't work as good without showing up to
an office I don't think I'm as
disciplined so I actually respect the
guys who do run remote companies a
tremendous amount and I think I would
love to get there there's probably some
kind of habits and disciplines I got to
build for myself to do that but there
hasn't been like a ten billion dollar
remote working company yet so I wonder
if it's possible to build to a certain
level but there's something about people
coming to an office every day about
building a culture I it does seem like
it works remote but I don't know if it's
gonna create the out sized return I
think technology is just getting to the
place where remote works right so you
haven't had ten billion dollar remote
company yet
because you haven't liked those
companies the technology didn't exist to
make those company ten years ten years
ago right that makes sense is you need
slack you need really good calm letting
up really really good web conferencing
if the web conferencing is annoying then
that's like that kills it right and then
you need the culture in the discipline
of you know doing regular meetings
bringing everybody together once every
whatever quarter or whatever I do think
that there's a lot of stuff that you
need together you kind of have to to do
yeah it didn't exist the technology and
the cultural technology didn't exist
before I think I am continue to be
flabbergasted by how poorly web
conferencing still works and how has
gotten better it's gotten better but you
know what the big the big issue is
humans insist on not plugging in
Ethernet cables and in arc I have an
office in Toronto with three employees
you know because we're doing the
arbitrage ourselves because it's
literally two-for-one in Toronto you
know and you can pay people really well
because of the currency exchange yeah
and the cost of living is third and I'm
just like please put an ethernet cable
in and use a proper headset with a stick
microphone like you're landing a plane
yeah and when you do those two things
Ethernet and you turn off your Wi-Fi on
your laptop and you have that stick
microphone it actually works
yeah who knew who knew I'm like just run
the Wi-Fi over Ethernet has technology
have technology but I'm running two
different companies I have inside where
it's remote you know and then I have
launch where it's not and I'm trying to
figure out like which is the right model
I'm torn I don't know I would love to I
wish I had it was better remote and I
kind of understood it more and I think
eventually hm we'll get there with as at
least as a multi office company it's
going to have to be so you're gonna have
to have some of that discipline